what one might call pure cinematics
the Assembly of of film and how it can
be changed to create a different idea
never ever close up they were sure what
he sees let's assume he saw a woman
holding a baby in her arms now we cut
back to his reaction to what he sees and
he smiles now what is he as a character
he is a kindly man he's sympathetic now
let's take the middle piece of film away
the woman with the child but leave his
two pieces of film as they were now
we'll put in a piece of film of a girl
in a bikini
he looks girl in a bikini
he smiles what is he now to tell the old
man is no longer the benign gentleman
who loves babies that's the difference
that's what film can do for you what you
just saw was groundbreaking director
Alfred Hitchcock discussing the power of
the montage to influence even change of
viewers opinion this is known as the
Kuleshov effect Soviet filmmaker Lev
Kuleshov showed the following clip to an
audience
[Music]
then you showed them this clip
finally this
the audience fervently remarked how the
expression on the man's face was
different in all three sequences one
showed hunger the next sadness and
finally lost as though they were all
shot independently this was not the case
the only difference between the free
shots is the image spliced in between
the close-up in all three examples the
close-up shot itself was the exact same
piece of film the man's expression did
not change
Kuleshov used this experiment to
demonstrate how the considered a
semblance of completely unrelated pieces
of images and film can significantly
alter a viewers emotional response this
simple yet powerful technique has been
used in propaganda to wage wars win wars
spread tyranny and keep it at bay it has
been using humanity's greatest films to
make audiences laugh sob and scared
senseless but there is one force in our
modern world that holds the Deaf des
stands the sly mere skill the most
astute ability to rearrange information
to influence nations change narratives
and breed mass contempt the media the
ability of the press TV news and
increasingly digital media to take the
truth and warp it to a line with their
ideological agenda is unrivaled
fastidiously straddling the legal
boundaries as they do so how you may ask
I'm sure you're all too aware of fake
news well I'm not talking about fake
news I mean to draw your attention to a
far more underhanded means of deception
utilized by what you may consider the
genuine media like most people you have
probably long suspected that the big six
media giants that controlled traditional
news or the new generation of digital
media haven't always reported stories to
you in the most genuine and factual
way but it's likely that you've never
quite been able to put your finger on
how or why this is because the
techniques they used to subvert the
truth are crucially subtle they are
required even mandated by law in certain
countries to be subtle so allow me to
enlighten you with just a few of the
many masterfully subtle subversions that
big media uses to sabotage the status
quo the media loves statistics why it's
not because statistics offer absolute
empirically factual truths in a concise
and easily digestible format no it's
quite the opposite the media lost
statistics because they can easily be
modified to support the narrative that
they wish to current story to tell in
2005 the state of Florida introduced a
controversial Stand Your Ground law
permitting people to use lethal force
against an attacker even if it would be
possible to safely retreat from the
situation without violence
Reuters published a following chart
showing the number of gun deaths in
Florida over time Wow you may remark gun
deaths dropped drastically following the
Stand Your Ground law of 2005 wrong
notice the y-axis has been inverted so
that the 0 is at the top a go as the
line graph flows down the charts the
number of gun deaths increases not
decreases this is purposely opposed to
the way in which we have been normalized
to expect the progression of data to
invariably appear on an XY axis chart we
naturally expect up to mean more not
less we also expect 0 to be at the
bottom left of the charts so then at
first glance it would appear that
following the 2005 statute Florida gun
deaths drops to almost zero now that
would be impressive another trick is
truncating the y-axis
the news loves to use his tactic with
crime statistics to make them sound more
rapturously apocalyptic how many times
have you read or heard news similar to
this murder rates up 100 percent on last
year what they often failed to report
are the actual numbers what if there was
only one murder last year if this year
there are two murders they're not is
indeed an increase of 100 percent on
last year but to the dismay of
professional fear-mongering frauds our
crime rates are usually extremely low to
begin with except in a few rare places
in the world so two murders in even a
small city of say 200,000 people is not
a statistic to give you court to
organize a sign writing party with your
belligerent blue-haired buddies so when
you're showing a chart such as this you
would be forgiven for thinking that the
interest rates up drastically between
2008 and 2012 if this were true then we
would all be donating our organs to pay
for our mortgages by now notice how the
y-axis is severely truncated to
exacerbate the most minut increments of
data plots the same data on a chart
where the baseline is set at zero and
what we can now observe is that the
interest rates in fact stage staunchly
started it's not always appropriate to
start a y-axis at zero sometimes to
demonstrate a huge shift in data within
a far greater range then the y axis must
be truncated but always be aware when
you suspect it has been done to mislead
you as it has an even more devious way
in this chart published by the Ministry
of Health for New South Wales in 2013
what's going on here is more subtle and
simply truncating in axis 43,000 nurses
are graphically represented by just four
nurse graphics yet twenty-eight nurse
graphics are then used to represent 46
files and nurses a numerical increase of
only 3,000 nurses
making the increase in nurses seem
astronomically higher between 2010 and
2011 when in fact there was only a 7%
increase
another way that information is often
misleadingly visualized is through false
correlations this graph humorously
suggests that there is a positive
correlation between ice cream sales and
murders but of course correlation
doesn't imply causation just because I
usually take tea around the same time
that the Pope holds his mourning mass it
doesn't mean that I am in any way
persuaded by the Supreme Pontiff spice
utterings
to enjoy a delicious pot of steeped tea
leaves nor does it imply that's my tea
consumption is some kind of religious
ceremony the deception that can be
wreaked by slapping arbitrary false
correlations on a visual chart has been
turned into somewhat of a fledgling
internet meme by some witty individuals
as can be seen in these frankly
brilliance examples a lowered GDP
increases penis size using internet
explorer leads to murder which to be
fair seemed entirely accurate to anyone
who has ever used Internet Explorer and
my favourites that global warming has
been caused by a decrease in the number
of pirates when the media isn't
distracted with developing duplicitous
graphics then it is usually divulging
duplicitous discourse one method by
which journalists fool a general public
is by using very broad assumptions to
slap incendiary labels on individuals
whom they don't quite agree with take a
look at this headline by the
left-leaning British newspaper The
Guardian you keep welcome social media
activists linked to alt right into party
this is the story that free YouTube's
free speech defenders Paul Joseph Watson
Marc Meacham counts dan Kula and Karl
Benjamin sargon of akkad have joined the
United Kingdom Independence Party UK the
party responsible for instigating this
series of events that led to breakfast
now I can't speak on behalf of these
individuals political views because I
don't know I cannot say whether or not
any of them personally identifies with
the old right any more than I can say
whether or not
Kim jong-un believes in Pampa days
followers of these youtubers would argue
that they are simply defenders of free
speech and that they all seek to
rationally object to the irrational
ideologies of the extreme left that is
so pervasive throughout contemporary
culture claims that these individuals
are linked to the old rites are widely
unsubstantiated and even the most
prominent rumors are pathetically flimsy
but that doesn't matter because sure
they have impressive supports online but
the majority of the general public and
especially Guardian readers have never
watched any of these free men's videos
nor is it very likely that they were
aware of their existence before reading
the subject article so by writing the
headline that they are linked to alt
writes the damage has already been done
most people will instantly consume
mental images of what we typically
associate with the alt right pointy hot
white supremacist neo Nazis etc etc
claiming that you keep has welcomes
these supposed white supremacist hate
mongers with a red carpet seeks to
dexterously defame you Kim
notice also how the carefully chosen him
is to accompany this headline is a
particularly smug looking mark Meacham
who and I'm sorry mark is definitely the
most typically alt-right looking of the
freemen in regards to appearance why
does it matter if headlines are
misleading because multiple studies
concur that a headlines bias hugely
affects the way that the rest of the
article is read and interpreted by that
person headlines providers with the
settled for the story we are about to
read and no matter of that story
contains conflicting information we
still view that information through the
lens of that bias that the headline has
pre constructed for us clinical studies
have proven how a news headline is
written positively or negatively affects
our opinion of something or someone far
more than the actual content does the
actual body of the article the wording
of the headline also dictates
what we remember most about the article
and how we will report it to our friends
later on that's assuming that people
actually read the article researchers
found the sin 59% of occurrences online
people read only the headline of a news
article and never actually click on it
to read the full article news outlets
know this
that's why headlines are and always have
been designed to be captivating but
often deceptive slapping unsubstantiated
labels on public figures to skew the
views of that individual in the eyes of
the impressionable general public thus
undermining that figures Authority is
one of the most widely used modus
operandi mobilized by the media in
today's heavily divided political
climates alt-right is a particular
favorite label because with that one
short compound word so much hateful
imagery can be instantaneously attached
to any individual even the most moderate
of social commentators such as Canadian
clinical psychologist dr. Jordan
Peterson have received this treatment
NBC News happily slaps the alt-right
label on him in this damning piece so
apparently having a rational fact-based
approach towards cultural and social
issues and inspiring people to take
responsibility for their own lives is
synonymous of being a Nazi there are
other examples available jordan peterson
also famously clashed with channel 4
journalist Caffey newman and it
perfectly illustrated another trick that
journalists do all the time use
manipulative language to put words in
the interviewees mouth in this
fascinating interview that has been
watched by over 14 million people
peterson carefully and logically d
constructs many commonly believed
fallacies about inequality in the
workplace and general life choices
between the two genders to which
caffeine newman simply responds with so
you're saying then a general
inflammatory statements that she
the viewers will react negatively to if
she can just convince them that this is
what Peterson actually meant whereas his
actual meaning was something entirely
different from what Newman's suggests
which is perfectly clear to anyone with
two ears and a brain between them
why does she repeatedly attempt to draw
false conclusions from Peterson's
rhetoric because she is intellectually
outclassed and she knows it she has no
rational counter arguments to Peterson
statements but she cannot do the valiant
thing and admit that Peterson's
arguments holds some ground because both
herself and the network she represents
have a certain ideological agenda to
push so she instead attempts to put
words in Peterson's mouth seeking to
besmirch his moral character other
linguistic tricks are commonly used by
journalists when interviewing and
anniversary now I would love to show you
some clips of the following techniques
in use but as I'm sure you can
appreciate how increasingly rigorous
copyright laws make it very difficult
for me to do so however there are
thousands of examples out there for you
to seek out if you wish to do so
and I'm sure you've noticed them in use
on a daily basis anyway so for instance
anchors and journalists will often fall
back on binary injunctions such as yes
or no just answer the question
yes or no when the opponent gives a
lengthy answer to a deeply nuanced
question that cannot possibly be
answered with a simple yes or no without
coming across as a belligerent fool
where none opponent uses empirical
evidence or commonly known axioms to
support their arguments it is common for
the interviewer to come back with the
ignorant response well that's your
opinion this is commonly used when the
interviewer knows that their opponent
just made a substantial and valid point
and they cannot intellectually retort it
so by instead chalking it up as just
their opinion it undermines the factual
foundations of the entire argument that
person just laid down
when introducing a guest it is common
for a news anchor talk show host or
other journalists to preface the
interview with something similar to John
Smith claims he is an avian expert but
his critics say he molest spigen x'
let's find out noticed a critical syntax
here but his critics say which critics
it is very rare that the critics who
supposedly said that are actually
identified a broad generalization such
as this rarely attracts calls for
substantiation and it doesn't matter
anyway
the damage has already been done in the
eyes of most people watching listening
or reading mr. Smith is now a pigeon
molester when in fact these critics
could consist of no more than the
journalists who just made that statement
witnessing a homeless man shouting
bloody pigeon molester and mr. Smith as
he innocently walks down the street it
would then be legally justified for such
a conjecture to exist even if it does
not represent greater public opinion
subtle phrasing such as but their
critics say is necessary in a world with
libel and slander laws because the
journalists themselves are not making
the vilification some mysterious critic
is I'll let you into a little secret
almost every time a journalist uses the
phrasing but his or her critics say
prepend is to a string of particularly
incendiary pejoratives it is actually a
means for the supposedly impartial
journalist to out their personal views
or that of their companies on the
character in question without personally
risking legal defamation an example can
be seen here on Toronto Life com
when u of t professor Jordan Peterson
pledged never to use gender-neutral
pronouns he sparked a vicious campus
battle the free speech advocates say
he's combating the tyranny of political
correctness his critics say he's a
privileged transphobic bigot who must be
stopped it's also worth mentioning the
statements that Jordan Peterson pledged
to never use gender-neutral pronouns in
that headline is just an outright lie
also if a journalist uses the word
allegedly before statements then it's
usually the exact same damn thing it's
just another way to say their critics
say such a linguistic trick such as this
that cunningly transmutes opinions into
facts are especially important thus
often utilized in in British news in the
UK impartiality laws exist under the
Communications Act of 2003 that legally
mandates news in any format to exercise
jus impartiality and jus accuracy in
2017 British regulator Ofcom ruled that
Fox News's Hannity and Tucker Carlson
tonight shows had breached these laws
but since Fox News no longer broadcast
in the UK they could not be fined news
is the mechanism by which public
opinions are formed and ideologies are
built upon it is therefore imperative
that when we see wild claims and
incendiary headlines that we choose to
dig a little deeper consult other
sources and build one's own balanced
opinion on the matter
instead of moronically blindly copying
that of a single biased journalist
especially in a world where we have
misleading headlines such as this girl
school still offering something special
head thanks for watching